hey guys welcome to a brand new video
today I'm to be going over five
profitable ways to train your magic I
get asked this question a lot I had to
train my magic level up and a lot of
people go to like alkene or stuff like
that and that's really not the best way
to go about it so today we're gonna be
looking over some good money making
methods that will give you a good amount
of magic experience now keep in mind a
lot of these are going to be bit higher
level like 60 magic plus but this is one
that really starts to slow down anyway
and it's good to have a good way to
train your magic that's actually
profitable or at least break even so you
don't actually waste all your money so
starting at number five is a pretty
well-known one but still good
nonetheless net is charging orbs that
we're gonna be doing air orbs they are
generally the most profitable however
not all the time to charge air orbs
you're going to need level 66 magic fire
orbs or 63 and earth and water down here
as well however air orbs are the
simplest to run and I like them the most
because of that you don't have to go
through a giant dungeon or go through
Jillie short guys or stuff like that you
just kind of run up the Moors it's
pretty easy what you're gonna need is a
air battle staff some weight-reducing
equipment however be careful because
this is going to be in the wilderness
and you want to make sure you're keeping
let's say your graceful if you die
you're gonna need a bunch of amulet of
Glory's cuz you're gonna be teleporting
back to edgeville and some energy
potions in the bank I bring with me a
super anti poison because I think
there's a spider that can poison me
which is a big pain in the ass you'll
need three times the amount of orbit
you're bringing in so I need eighty one
cosmic runes for that so it's possible
to gain about 35 K to 40 K magic
experience which isn't the highest by
any means but you are going to be
getting between 300 and 500 K an hour
doing this method so it's definitely
worth it for that reason if you do it
right at level 66 you're gonna be lovely
enough fairly quickly and actually
making some decent cash I wouldn't
really recommend doing this once you get
into the 70 80s or 90s because it's just
not quick enough to Train magic and it's
gonna take way too long and there are
other better message to choose from
coming in number four is actually
something I would recommend doing it a
lower level if possible and that is
killing lavage or AI games now this is
something that's really good when you
are very low combat
because the main danger here is P cares
and that is the main problem and what
makes us balanced when you're low level
almost nobody will be able to kill you
here because they can't attack you so
when your level combat level like 10 to
20 is when you'll be your strongest and
safest here the money per hour can vary
quite a bit based on the drops you get
am I gonna scare to show somebody no and
the XP for our really depends on what
spell you're gonna use the beauteous
method is you can bring whatever [__]
gear you wanna like I'm bringing the
[__] wizard hat brims robe top and
mystic boots I didn't [__] matter
just bring stuff that you can afford to
lose and doesn't risk it very much you
could probably get 30 40 K an hour here
with fire blast or a fire bolt and it's
gonna scale down based on what spell
you're using however you will profit the
most with the cheapest spell as well so
you really do have to be paying
attention because P cares will jump on
you a lot and there's just no way
getting around it it is actually
possible to safe spot them from over
here if you want and you can tell they
grab the loot however there is vety on
down here which it rolls you a bunch too
so it's kind of depends on what you
prefer the most you're a little bit
safer down there but really if you do
this at an off peak hour where not many
people are playing and you're paying
attention here you can pretty much
always log off on time so it's not that
big a deal
if I were to guess a GP per hour on a
very low level like maybe 40 magic and
really low combo level you're probably
only gonna get 3 or 400 K an hour if
you're uninterrupted however you can get
upwards of 700 and retain our at higher
combat levels but there is a risk reward
kind of deal they're coming in number 3
is actually the plank make spell now
this one doesn't get used a whole lot
but I'm not really sure why because if
you actually use the spell on mahogany
logs you actually profit a bit every
cast you'll need the lunar diplomacy
quest done as well as level 86 magic we
serve a price checker open here so we
can see the material cost to use one
cast of this is about 2001 mahogany
plank is worth 2130 now you can do about
1500 to 1800 cast an hour which is gonna
net you somewhere in the range of 200 K
an hour which money-wise not that great
but it's be wise you're looking at 130 K
to 100
in 60k an hour somewhere in that range
and to use the spell is really easy kind
of click intensive though so to use this
spell it's a pretty simple one-to-one
ratio one plank make equals one spell
there's not really any pro way to do
this you just kind of have to get used
to the rhythm make sure you're doing it
on the right tick and you can get quite
a bit of experience you will need quite
a bit of cash because actually casting
the spell cost 1000 coins as well as the
room cost and the logs but I would say
well worth it especially since you're
going to be profiting you can just sell
the logs right back and just continue on
coming in at number two is the spin flax
Bell now this one is particularly good
as of recently because when you make all
update bow strings have risen up in
price quite a bit so again to do this
quest you'll need to have lunar so lunar
diplomacy is a must to be done on top of
that you'll need a bit of cash but on a
ton and you will need 76 magics a bit
lower than the other one as we have a
look at the price of the items here
you'll need to nature ruins and astral
rune and you can do 5 flex at a time
bringing your prerequisite cost to about
600 and if we look at the price of 5 bow
strings you're looking at about 780 so
we're looking at 180 GP profit per cast
and you can do between 900 and thousand
an hour so about 160 to kgp per hour
which isn't too bad however you're gonna
be getting between 60 and 75 K magic
experience but the main benefit you're
gonna be getting an equal amount in
crafting so forgetting 70 K magic
experience an hour you're getting 70 K
crafting expand our which is a huge
benefit cuz the crafting is normally
really expensive and is just a great way
to love up crafting so to actually do
this method I would recommend having
your runes as well as an extra item in
your inventory because you're gonna be
doing it in batches of five so you can't
do 30 so 25 will be your best and if you
don't have an extra item you can
accidentally use this spell on just one
flax which will be a waste of money but
yeah essentially every cast is equal to
five flax you have to cast it five times
and just count it and you just have to
get used to you the timing it's a lot
easier for sounds on that's for five and
then your screen to bank your items
which are more flax easy as that and
great money-making radix be and
a really good method overall in coming
in number one is ice bursting dust
devils or neck rails or other monsters
in the game but I'm gonna be doing this
one as an example
so the ice burst things you will need 70
magic as well as desert treasure done
for the ancient magic spell book on top
of that you will need access to Quran
and into the catacombs this is the best
way to kill them for gear there's a
couple ways you can do it I'm bringing
investment robes which actually give you
a prayer bonus or kind like a proselyte
version for magic and you will need a
slayer helmet or at least a face mask
ideally you do this on task but you
really don't have to the reason this is
breakeven is because the dust levels
actually drop quite a bit of profitable
stuff mainly they drop a ton of battle
slabs or air battle staff and on top of
that they also drop tons of runes herbs
and coins that are actually add up to
quite a bit per hour and you also have a
rare chance of getting a dragon chain
body very rare and a dust battle staff
also quite a few alcohols so I'm
bringing some out groans and last up you
will also need darts or arranged twitch
or something to aggro all the monsters
together first up just throwing protect
from melee equip all your darts and you
just need to add grow all of the dust
devils first don't need to really do any
damage and having a blowpipe is nice
because it gives you a little more range
but then you have to you actually waste
solver skills which is not as ideal
afterwards you're gonna switch back to
your ancient magics pop on ice burst and
basically you're just gonna run into
this little L shape here and wait for
all of the dust devils to actually kind
of meld into each other kind of takes a
little while to get used to but it's
really not that hard once it all stacked
on each other you could just attack and
you get pretty massive expedia HP here
can vary a bit depending on how well
you're doing this but it goes pretty
much from 100 K to 150 K now ur
being on task is extremely helpful
because you're gonna do more damage the
effectiveness of magic equipment here is
not extremely high these guys have
extremely low defense you're not going
to notice a big difference between using
stuff like the vestment robes and using
magic gear unless you have ancestral in
which case I would definitely go ahead
and use that you're mainly going to be
doing this for the experience but the
Prophet is more of a break-even prophet
look I already got a
air battle staff your main cost is gonna
be the runes but just make sure you pick
up everything that's including chaos
runes and even burn arrows once you've
killed the whole stack you just go back
to a Gore and everything together now
the reason the bone crusher is really
useful here is because these guys all
drop bones and every bone you bury in
the current underground gives you one
prayer point so prayer potions are gonna
last an exceedingly long time like I've
only used ten prayer points right now
and I've already been doing this for
like a minute so really your prayer
points are going to go a long way you
want to make sure you pick up the cash
tax here too you can see there's a 5k
clean stack on the ground honestly if
you want to make this even more afk even
bring a ring of wealth because picking
up the kind of petty cash can be a
little annoying but yeah that's pretty
much it guys I hope you enjoyed the
video and maybe you learned something if
you did don't forget to toss the video
like really appreciate it and I'll see
you the next one
you